actor jeff daniels has proved he can
play any role he made us laugh out loud
in dumb and dumber in the 90s and he
recently played a character who will do
anything for what he believes is right
now he is doing double duty in a new
showtime series as an executive producer
and a star it's called american rust
showtime is division of viacomcbs
daniels plays a police chief in a former
steel town in pennsylvania check it out
i'm good thanks you sure
on duty
i still care too much what people think
you don't seem to care what the county
judge thinks
i was under the impression you're
supposed to be catching bad guys not
serving as a lawyer i did catch them and
i locked them up
the question now is whether the d.a is
going to embarrass herself by charging a
kid with a felony for a bar fight
especially when the other kid came after
him cut him first with a bayonet i mean
where do you even get a bayonet they're
not kids that's a good point another man
came after him with a bayonet
daniels is also returning to broadway as
atticus finch and tequila mockingbird
good morning and welcome to our new
studio jeff what's up morning nate go
lions that's right go lions glad you
said that we'll see how they do this
season um but but we'll get to american
rust in a second you started rehearsals
um after almost two years away um for to
kill a mockingbird what was it like to
be back
a lot of it was still there
that was the first thing two almost two
years since i even said the words and
then you pick up the script this summer
and you're going
oh i know this like old song lyrics yeah
you remembered from songs you like
uh i think i could use a little atticus
finch in my life right now i think
america could use a little atticus finch
in our lives and so that was the that
and helping broadway reopen helping new
york city get back on his feet
if if me coming back into mockingbird
helps that then then yeah but i i i want
to come back into atticus today and see
how it's different from when we did it
being on stage is a unique experience
what did you miss the most
i missed uh and look forward to the the
the closing argument that atticus finch
delivers right
and
you at the end of the last third of the
closing argument i turn to the audience
and i treat them like the jury
and you have 1400 of the most
sophisticated theatergoers predominantly
white
sitting in the shubert theater
not moving
not i mean they're pinned back it's so
quiet actors dream of roles like that of
moments like that and it happens eight
times a week on that show
i can't wait listen when you say talk
about actors dream of certain roles i'm
curious about american rust because i
read that you read this book 12 years
ago and were you holding on to it saying
one day i'm going to do this
i'd read it i'd met philip meyer he did
a book reading here in new york city and
i went down to see this new author debut
novel great book read bought the book
read the book yeah it's really great not
in a position to get anything made i'm
trying to keep the career going yeah
but then that thing that happens that
people say when do you know when you've
made it i knew i'd made it when my agent
eddie called and said yeah we could do
this or we could do that but what do you
want to do
american rust
book i have and and that was i don't
know a couple years ago two years three
years ago once you had that power of all
the things you could do why that why
american rust i hadn't played him before
a character police chief is that what
you mean you hadn't played a police
officer is that what you mean
yeah that i hadn't played a cop so that
was you know that was on the list but i
knew dale harris i grew up in michigan i
worked at my dad's lumber company i
drove truck i did all that i delivered i
did all that stuff i'm around those guys
i was that small town kid that had the
acting thing not worked out that's where
i'd be i'd be back at that lumber
company with my brother and
run in the family lumber company in a
small with with that
i am that guy uh-huh so
when i saw the dell harrison american
rest i'm going i want to
go in there and philip meyer what he did
and what dan futterman did with the
series just you go deeper and deeper and
and i'm doing things in this show that
i've never done in any other like like
what jeff well there's the opioid deal
i'm on the va cocktail which is uh
benzedrine klonopin and zoloft i think
and i'm trying to detox myself off it
and so there's there's that and when it
doesn't go well i mean there's the
the detox
i
there's a crime that happens and i get a
little too involved in it
um
looks like you might have crossed a line
or two yeah and then later on in the in
the series
uh i get i get to do some things that i
i i have never done
on screen okay that's a good tease let's
talk about it's a tease but i can't say
no no that that's good we like it tease
when you think about dumb and dumber if
you're sitting at home and it comes on
do you stay and watch it what do you
think about it how does that sit i'll
stick around a little bit with it
yep still funny it is very
very funny we didn't know at the time my
kids yell at me when i make them watch
classic movies which for them is movies
from the 90s they love dumb and dumber
thank you it's just uh
i remember doing the toilet scene and uh
and and i'm going i should and jim
carrey's sitting next to me and jim
i'm going he goes what's man what's
wrong man i'm going well
it's either the beginning of my career
or the end
it's going to be great at the moment jim
taught me to be fearless
let's just say a great gift jeff daniels
your talent is very wide and vast this
is true as long as you're current one of
the best business
and go lions that's right thank you jeff
american russ premier says sunday on
showtime which by the way is a division
of icon cbs and to kill a mockingbird
this is big reopens on broadway october
5th jeff will be there very busy we'll
be right back